Speaker 1: All right.
Let's follow the 2024 campaign trail around
the weekend and take a look at what happened.
Donald Trump was scheduled to do another one
of these unhinged lie rallies.
The lie is second.
It's not even lie a minute.
It's the lie.
A second rally in Des Moines, Iowa.
That rally was ultimately canceled.
It was reportedly canceled for bad weather,
although there are some who are saying it
was canceled because there were no people
and Trump realized it would be humiliating.
So we opted to cancel it.
I don't know.
Officially, it was canceled for bad for bad
weather.
This didn't stop the sycophants and dilettantes
from showing up and praising the cult leader
and really proving beyond any doubt whatsoever
that this is a cult.
I'm going to show you a few examples of this
at the rally that did not happen.
Here is a guy who was asked, you know, Trump's
doing a rally in Iowa.
Ron DeSantis is also doing an event in Iowa,
even though he's not yet running.
And this guy says he felt an obligation to
be at the Trump rally.
Why?
I'll let him explain it to you.
I wasn't.
Speaker 2: Important today.
We've got DeSantis in the same state today.
But you guys chose to be here for President
Trump.
Was the decision making process there?
Speaker 3: You want to go first?
Speaker 4: I think all of the attacks against
President Trump that are just totally unprecedented,
you know, the legal allegations against him,
I just feel obligated knowing how much President
Trump has stood up for me and has stood up
for all of these Americans.
I feel obligated to come out here and show
my support for him.
Yeah.
Speaker 1: What now?
See, this is where, like, if we had Luke Beasley
on the ground, he would follow up and say,
Oh, in what way did Trump stand up for you?
Well, he stood up to China for me.
Oh, really?
How did he stand up to try?
And you very quickly see that it's completely
vapid.
It's just there's absolutely no substance
whatsoever there.
Then they go to the guy next to him with a
basically the same question.
DeSantis is in the state of Iowa.
Trump was scheduled to be in the state of
Iowa before the rally got canceled.
Why are you here instead of at the DeSantis
event?
And listen to what this guy says.
It's beyond parody.
Speaker 3: This is a promise made, promises
kept, and Trump is the only president ever
that has traded his wealth for his country
and not his country for his.
Speaker 1: Not his country for his wealth.
Trump earned $1.6 billion personally during
his presidency.
Think about the level of disconnect with these
people.
Trump did something no one else has ever done.
He traded his wealth for the country, for
the good of the country.
He earned $1.6 billion during the four years
that he was supposedly working for this guy's
interests as president of the United States.
Then they speak to.
We're still dealing with the same group of
folks.
They speak to one of the women, I guess, and
say, if you had the chance to speak to Donald
Trump, what would you say to him?
Unidentified: Mr. Trump, you are a true American
hero.
We love you.
Speaker 2: Your are the true American bad
ass that we have been waiting for.
Unidentified: And we thank you.
You're like our father, our protector, and
we love you.
Thank you.
Speaker 1: Folks.
Folks, intervention is the word that comes
to mind.
This is a very deep and troubled cult.
And this is the sort of, you know, there was
a time.
I know people sometimes get upset when I do
this.
There was a time where if you went and in
fact, you can look at this on YouTube and
I know some people say, David, you're glamorizing
terrible.
Okay, just bear with me.
If you go on YouTube and you find examples
of right wingers from the sixties and seventies
who would go to, for example, a William F
Buckley, Noam Chomsky debate or something
like that, and they would get on the mic and
they would ask a question.
Okay, They will seem like the most sane and
rational intellectuals compared to these folks.
Now, in fact, if you look at the Trump CNN
town hall from last week and you look at the
questions that were asked, people who can
barely string a sentence together, and then
you look at the folks that would engage, you
know, with William F Buckley and others in
the 6780s of the United States.
The right.
I am on the left.
Okay.
So I would come to different conclusions on
policy than these folks.
But there were people on the right in the
United States back then who didn't seem obviously
like empty vessels.
Just following a cult leader without understanding
a word about it.
You go and look at there's some very interesting
videos on YouTube where the economist Milton
Friedman takes questions from the audience.
And some of the questions are from people
on the left.
And some of the questions are for people on
the right.
The level of discourse was you just can't
even compare it to what has happened to this
country, particularly from the anti-intellectual
and pseudo pseudo intellectual left where
college is liberal, indoctrination and books
are sissy and all of this stuff.
And this is where we end up with cult members.
That's where we are at this point in time.
Here is a guy from the same rally that was
postponed who, without evidence says to the
anchors of Real America's Voice.
Someone from New York has been paying for
my dad's cancer treatment and I'm sure it's
Donald Trump.
What?
Do you have any evidence of that?
No, but I'm just sure that my dad hasn't received
a cancer bill in over five years, and.
Speaker 3: It's been paid.
Speaker 1: 100% by a guy in New York.
And that can only be President Donald Trump
and my dad's cancer free.
Well, yeah, that's just made up, guys.
There's no reason whatsoever.
And by the way, Trump hasn't lived in New
York for years.
Trump, famously, while he was president, changed
his residency to floor like this.
None of this makes sense.
There's no thinking.
There's no thinking that's happening here.
It is just people praying at the altar of
the cult leader.
TRUMP The question of the Jean Carroll case
did come up in interviews with some of these
supporters.
We'll go back to that earlier group we looked
at and they were asked, well, what do you
think about the Eugene Carroll thing?
And here's what they had to say.
Women for Trump.
Speaker 2: Yeah.
Are you deterred at all by any of the recent
allegations against him, or are you just supporting
Trump through and through?
Because you know that he's an honest man.
He may.
We think it's a lie and yeah, yeah, yeah.
I mean, he's a good guy.
They just don't like it because he's standing
up for America.
They have demonized him because he's the one
standing up for we the people.
He's the only president, the only person who
has ever stood up for we the people.
He's on our side.
And that's why he's been demonized, because
all the systems that have been in control
are rigged.
Speaker 1: Right.
A jury, which included Trumpists, found that
Trump was liable for the sexual assault and
defamation of Jean Carroll because the jury
was angry that Trump stood up for the American
people.
You sound I sound like an idiot repeating
it.
It's so stupid.
It doesn't make any sense whatsoever.
Here's one last clip of folks proudly talking
about the parts of the country they came from
to see this rally.
Tornado watch be damned.
Speaker 2: Great to see you.
How are you doing?
I'm doing great.
Little wet, but I'm drying off.
So were you here during the little the little
rain?
Yes.
Speaker 1: After entering.
Speaker 2: The closeout.
Now, did people stay?
Did people run?
What was it like?
I never saw anyone leave.
Isn't that incredible?
Incredible.
I got a video, actually, of just hundreds
of people waiting out here early.
Hundreds.
And they didn't it they didn't move a muscle.
They stayed right here waiting to show their
support for.
Speaker 1: Proudly ignoring dangerous weather.
Speaker 2: President Trump Now, speaking of
support for President Trump, the front row
jokes have always been some of the most vocal
supporters.
I want to know today where each of you all
came from.
When did you leave?
How far is that journey?
Hey, Becky.
We left the day before yesterday and just
took our time.
I'm from Tennessee.
I came with Mike Bowman.
He's from Indiana.
Mike Bowman, what about South Dakota?
6 hours.
And how far did you travel and when did you
leave?
I came here yesterday.
It took me about 11.
Speaker 1: Hours from Ohio.
Okay.
So as you can see, a badge of honor, The more
that you have struggled and the more that
you have suffered to be in the presence of
the great leader, the more commitment you
have demonstrated.
This is straight out of a cult playbook, straight
out of a cult that you brag about who has
toiled and suffered the most to be here today.
Scary stuff.
Many of these people vote.
Trump could win in 2024.
And so we need to be on our guard.